we've got a voicemail number two one
nine to david p yesterday someone called
in and started reading from some sacred
text i think it was Isaiah and I said
why what's the point of calling in with
that the same caller called in and
explained why he called and read Isaiah
to me take a listen to this Dave uh I
guess yes but I was trying to
communicate when I called you the other
night about the scriptures like I was
just reading them basically all I was
trying to demonstrate in a nutshell of
about three minutes so it took so long
that just as I believe this is the end
of the world of bandhas as this system
of things ah okay well that clarifies it
we were wondering why he called in read
scripture Pat and it's because he was
trying to explain to me that it's the
end of the world now it makes sense yeah
I mean if the nutshell only took three
minutes for an explanation I wonder what
the whole thing would have been driving
like a hour-long lecture if the short
version of the end of the world was
three minutes then I I don't even want
to know what the long version is but
anyway we've clarified that we've got a
great bonus show for you today trust me
I don't even have time to tell you about
it but you can sign up for the bonus
show at david pakman.com slash
membership or through making a $5 pledge
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
see you then